-Hi, Jessica, how are you?
-I'm good. How are you?
-I'm doing wonderful.
It's lovely to see you.
You know, one of the trickiest
parts of this time
we're living through is people
not seeing loved ones.
But you're very lucky.
You're actually quarantining
with your grandmother.
-Yes, my grandmother
was quarantining by herself.
She started in February.
She was ahead of the whole
government, you know,
recommendation,
and she got really lonely.
So, starting beginning of April,
she drove to my house,
and we have been quarantining
ever since.
We're exercising and cooking.
And she's a good hangout buddy.
-That's pretty great
because not a lot of people,
you know, in adulthood
get to spend that much
quality time with a grandparent.
So, in a way, you guys
have found
a pretty nice silver lining.
-Yeah, I mean,
she's a pretty cool grandparent.
You know, her Instagram handle
is, like, @motorcyclegramma,
so, you know,
she's not your typical grandma.
-Yeah, that's definitely --
I'm pretty sure that handle
was available
when she went looking for it.
-She didn't have to fight
for that one.
It's not "motorcyclegramma1."
-Right. [ Laughs ]
So, congratulations
on this movie.
This is a female-led,
female-produced spy thriller
called "The 355."
And the name
has significance, right?
-Yeah.
I learned about 355, the name,
from actually the consultant
that I'd worked with
on "Zero Dark Thirty,"
and she told me that 355
was the code name
for the first female spy during
the American Revolution.
And no one knows her real name
to this day,
but that was how
she was acknowledged.
She was this invisible person
who really,
you know, helped us --
helped our country.
So, women today in espionage
in the United States
use that moniker
as a badge of honor, like, 355.
The women doing the work
behind the scenes.
-And this was your idea, right?
To have a movie like this
that had a bunch of, you know,
female action stars
doing an espionage thriller.
It's sort of based on the fact
that you were seeing
that it was happening
on the other side.
-Yeah, I had seen so many movies
with, you know,
ensembles with male actors
that were great films
and great actors.
But I was wondering, like, why
don't we have movies with women?
I had known that in real life
women are at the forefront
of espionage.
And it kind of, in some sense,
was a wish list of mine.
Because I got to work
with Penelope Cruz
and Lupita Nyong'o
and Diane Kruger
and Fan Bingbing and
these incredible actresses
that, you know, in the past, our
industry hasn't been so great
at allowing more than one woman
on a set at the same time.
They don't want us
in the same room.
So, yeah, I wanted to do it,
and I guess
I kind of made it happen.
-You, I guess, presented
the idea that a film like this
would necessarily
then need a Bond Boy,
the sort of alternative
to the Bond Girls that
we've gotten used to over
the last, I guess, 50 years.
And was that --
How were you greeted
with the idea of the Bond Boy?
-Well, you know, I had realized
that men have been discriminated
against for so long
because they had only been
known for their skills
and their talent
and their knowledge
and the things that they say,
and they were not acknowledged
for their sexual desirability
in the way that women have had.
So I thought, you know what?
It's about time
we do men justice
and let's have some Bond Boys.
So, I just said it as a tweet,
as a joke,
and the funny thing is
I actually received requests
and submissions from people
to be Bond Boys.
-That's -- I mean,
that says a lot because
based on the history
of Bond Girls,
you're really
on the chopping block
as far as your character's,
you know, ability
to survive a whole film.
But you got some pretty --
You got some really nice hunks
in this film.
I tip my cap.
-Yeah. I will say.
And also, too, it's time
that the guys
get to be eye candy, too.
-Yeah. Why not?
You know, they're the ones
that are floating
in the middle of a pool
and somebody goes, "Whoa."
-Well, I don't want
to give too much away,
but I will say
that not all of them
have a successful journey
in our film.
-Hey, such is the life
of a Bond Boy.
You know what?
You get what you sign up for.
We actually have a trailer.
You know, we didn't show a clip
on the way in because we have
something a little more
substantial to show.
So let's take a quick look.
-The threat's
not on the horizon.
It's here. Right now.
We're the only ones that
can prevent World War III.
I'm putting together a team, and
you're the best at what you do.
-We all work for different
intelligence agencies --
American, British, Colombian,
German, Chinese.
♪♪
But now we need to join forces.
-They have an army.
-What do we have? And please
don't say each other.
-Never.
-I'm scared.
-Good.
Only an idiot isn't scared.
♪♪
-We're The 355.
-I like the new team.
-We'll take it from here.
♪♪
-I'm very pro anything that has
the line "joining forces."
I like that a great deal.
-A lot of great movies
have had that line.
Rival agents joining forces.
-Right.
You're watching the trailer
saying,
"I hope they can make it work."
You had to return to production.
Was it in London?
Is that where you went back
to finish up filming?
-Yeah, that's where we --
That was our base
for when we shot the film.
And then we did some additional
scenes right in the middle
of this whole 2020 situation
we're in.
So in July, we went,
and it was quite an ordeal.
You know, testing all the time.
We didn't have any cases.
Thank goodness.
We were very, very careful
and very safe.
And so I guess it proved
that it can be done.
-One of the steps
you had to take personally
was the self test.
I have also -- You know, we have
protocols in place here.
And it's a mix of being tested
and then also the self-swabbing.
How do you feel like you did
as a self-swabber?
-Well, in the beginning,
I was terrible.
Because, you know, you think --
You see all the --
hear the horror stories
about it has to go
all the way up your nose.
And I was like, "This is
just not going to work."
And I was always crying.
And then I just got used it.
And the instructions say --
Just, you know, you stop when
you feel a gentle resistance.
As soon as I realized that, I
was like, "This is super easy."
And I still do it, actually,
because quarantining
with my grandmother,
I want to make sure that there's
a safe environment
that we're in.
I want to be responsible
to the people around me.
So I test myself regularly.
-A couple times a week, I am
doing the self-swab, as well.
And I can't believe
I've reached this point.
And it's really depressing
to be in a place where I'm like,
"I think I'm really good
at this now.
I think I'm a really good
self-swabber."
-"I am so good
at putting things up my nose."
-It's also really fun to think
of someone who's in that trailer
being like, "Uh, I don't want
to put anything up my nose!"
-We actually did a --
I will say --
I'm sure you're really good
at it, but I did hear
that there were a lot
of big babies on our set,
and some of the biggest babies
have the biggest muscles.
-[ Laughs ]
-Then I meant to say
I was a baby about it.
So great to see you
as always, Jessica.
I really look forward
to the film.
And hopefully next time
we can see you in person.
-I know. I look forward
to being in a room together.
And let's finish off this year
in a great place.
Nowhere to go but up, right?
-That's sounds like
a very accurate framing
of the situation we're in.
-Yes.